perception is projection what's that
mean it means that you see what you
expect to
see you perceive your own projections of
the world uh you had that [__] hyperv
viral moment about the scar makeup tell
tell it again for the people so they did
an experiment where they told a group of
women that they're going to put scarring
on their faces or visual disfigurements
of some kind and then they would go in
into an interview and the purpose of the
experiment is to work out whether the
interviewer is going to treat them
differently because of their fysal
facial disfigurement what they didn't
tell the women is as they were leaving
to go for the interview they touched up
their makeup and without showing them
the facial disfigurement removed the
scarring so they went into the interview
thinking they're facially scarred but
they weren't and they came back
reporting massive levels of
discrimination specific comments that
the interview had made about them that
they perceived so you you you see what
you expect to see this is why teaching
people victimhood is so dangerous
because it makes them victims it makes
them expect certain things and then they
will react differently I mean you know
police interactions are a good example
of this if you expect that the police
are going to treat you badly because of
who you are you're going to act in a
different way and therefore cause more
problems and I say this to somebody you
know I was a very angry young man and I
and my wife used to piss me off so much
she would constantly say like I'd get
into an argument with somebody and I'd
be like that guy's a prick he did this
and she'd be like you are creating those
situations you know that right and I was
like no you and it took me like a good
10 years to work out absolutely I was
ABS [__] lutely I was right so we we
perceive the things that we put out into
the world and this is you know Peterson
talks about this is you can't see
without hierarchy because your brain has
to know what to focus on and what you
focus on is a function of the filter
that you project onto the world I'm
focusing on you now instead of the
bookshelf behind you I could have been
sitting here picking out a good book
this entire time it's been a waste but
so that's that's what's happening there
but it's interesting I mean I said
something at the time I was like look
these creepy men need to stop staring at
women in gyms otherwise they're going to
stop wearing lingerie to go there and
then everybody
loses and and what I'm the point I'm
trying to make is that like you
know this is a very I'm going to say
something very controversial here Chris
you ready men are attracted to
women I've heard about that let's sit
with that for a moment I've heard about
that so you know this idea
that you're going to be barely clad and
men aren't going to notice that yeah
sorry that's that's not what our brains
are for learn our brains are for looking
at your ass that's what they're for
that's what they evolved for I know it's
crudely put I learned the term for this
new style of Jim short it's got what's
called a butt scrunch right have you
seen the butt scrunch yes right yeah
you're a married man online of course
yeah someone showed me a photo I tried
to look away um yeah it which is for the
people that haven't seen it and aren't
training in gyms with like 20-year-olds
in it's like a normal pair of shorts
training shorts for a girl like kind of
tight but then it's got kind of like a
thong bit that separates the ass cheeks
out um which has been normalized very
quick do you remember when do you
remember the first time that wearing
just leggings became a thing cuz I do
because it wasn't when I went to UNI so
it's after 2006 it was after maybe it
happened while I was at Uni so maybe
before
2010 but I remember thinking wow that's
like that's like everything on display
that's kind of like kind of like no
pants yeah but then also kind of not and
then now it's like oh that's kind of
like no pan well like that's kind of
like just a thong but blue or like
purple or Lilac I feel you've dedicated
a lot of time to describing this
accurately which I appreciate I'm I'm an
casual orthologist on the side um I
wanted to tell you about this can I can
I say something just on that before you
move on because I think we we sort of
like we're we're trying to pretend
things all the time
which yes men shouldn't be pigs right we
can all agree on that but in order to
not be a pig I first have to see your
ass that you've shoved in my face right
so I see it I am then after that not a
pig right but I see it and it's there
and there's my brain isn't calibrated or
designed or evolved I mean the the sole
purpose of our genes is to reproduce
right how is that you see what I'm
saying well there's a female frame
that's placed around this conversation
specifically that I don't think
fully maybe go as far as to say like
sympathizes with
the male brain reward system there is an
inbuilt reward system that men have for
looking at sexually gratifying objects
even things like two rocks that look a
bit like boobs right right what's the
first thing a boy does when he gets a
calculator right
boobs yep now is that because of toxic
masculinity or is that because men
evolved for millions of years throughout
evolutionary history including preum
animals to seek the opposite sex and the
drive in males is just overwhelmingly
strong now once you have noticed that
how you act is where culture and society
and civilizing Men comes in right just
because you saw someone's ass doesn't
need doesn't mean that you allowed to go
and stare at it or grab it or whatever
but you saw it and you're
not it's it's almost like it happens and
then you're like okay I need
to [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah that's how
it works now what do you want me to do
about
that what are you supposed to do about
that I'm open to suggestions blinkers
blinker
men big some people would be in favor of
that big Veil that goes over the top
right little bit of inside baseball for
people who aren't familiar with what's
going on in the podcasting world and
apparently this one's slipped by you as
well